first wanted to touch on this area of
bakmut and why there's currently so much
Focus there from the Russians it's back
not in the East there's no real
strategic or operational rationale
behind where they're focused there but
they've been fighting to try and take
back now for weeks in fact months and
we're currently on day 284 of Vladimir
Putin's 10-day special military
operation
um and the Russians have been pouring
lots and lots of more manpower material
building their defenses around there and
recently they've tried a three-axis
Attack One just to the north one into
the City and one which has had a little
bit of success in the South as they try
and encircle it it's more becoming an
emotional Focus rather than a military
focus and actually I think ukrainians
are wanting that as well let's touch on
on what's likely in the months ahead
winter upon us is that a game changer
for what's possible winter is an
influencer rather than the game changer
it's a game changer for
um the difference between the ability to
attack defend the ground is very very
muddy and we're seeing your pictures
here of of of a tank on some of the
muddy ground that doesn't reflect just
how bad some of it is
um and it gets the point where even
tracked Vehicles can't get through it
and we saw that last year where the mud
just sticks armored vehicles into the
ground that stops armored formations to
maneuver in the way that you need to
carry out an attack it favors Defenders
so it's favoring the Russians at the
moment in the area but it's stopping
these these large-scale attacks so
that's where the biggest influence comes
in then you've got the cold and The Damp
and the wet and if you've got the troops
that are properly equipped that can
handle it their morale is going to stay
good if you've got troops who aren't
equipped and aren't getting fed and
can't handle it their morale is going to
go down that is where the Russians are
as opposed to the ukrainians who've got
the right kid the ukrainian's very well
prepared for the cold in the winter or
just less poorly prepared than the
Russians um well you know this is their
country this is their territory so their
military is used to working through
these sorts of conditions so you're from
a psychological perspective are well
prepared from a an environmental
perspective they've grown up and they've
trained in all of this their motivation
is keeping them going and they've got
you know Western Equipment coming in
they're being resupplied they're getting
fed in many cases whereas the Russians
don't necessarily have the winter gear
there's so many stories going around
about the troops not getting fed
um when the temperatures get really low
believe me it's morale sapping when
you're in those conditions I can
certainly imagine it um let's talk about
what the ukrainians are doing to to
counter some of these in recent weeks
Russian counter-offensive yeah well
they're they're blunting the Russian
counter fences in in
um backwood and that seems to be the
only area that Russia Russia is
attacking Ukraine's Got gone dark
elsewhere they've gone quiet remember
they've just had the success down in the
South around hereson
um there have been reports of the last
couple of days of Ukrainian troops
getting to the other side of the of the
river that that's improving different
areas but if the ukrainians can keep the
Russians fixed in that Central bit it
gives them freedom of maneuver drills
were what are the ukrainians focusing on
they're focusing on shipping the
battlefield so they're attacking Russian
Logistics impact on the winter lack of
food and everything else and attacking
their command and control so that the
Russians haven't got the commanders and
they're very short of good commanders
um I haven't got the commanders to try
and react to any Ukrainian
um counteroffensive that's going to come
in when the ground allows it